Alright,
so as you guys know,
I've spent a lot of time on the Rubin
report talking about the current status
of the left.
As I've said many times,
I believe the regressive left the group
of people who use illiberal tactics to
silence those defending liberal
principles to be the left's version of
the tea party.
If we don't reign them in now,
then the left in America will end up as
fractured as the right evidence of the
fractured right is everywhere with
basically every mainstream conservative,
actively trying to stop the parties.
Front runner,
Donald Trump.
Has there ever been a time when a front
runner on either side was so hated by
his own party's establishment?
Not that I know of,
and interestingly,
this mess is actually of the gops own
doing.
They didn't see the rise of the tea
party until it was too late,
which set the gop establishment against
their own base.
Ironically,
had the tea partiers been willing to
negotiate with anyone.
Perhaps the Republican party would be in
a better state than the ideological mess
it's in right now.
That didn't happen though,
and when you couple of fractured right
with the rise of the regressive left,
who refused to talk honestly about
issues like Islamic extremism and
immigration,
we now have the rise of Donald trump.
Before I continue,
let me say a couple of positive things
about Donald Trump.
Believe it or not,
uh,
I probably should have issued a trigger
warning there.
But,
uh,
getting your safe space.
Here we go.
All right.
He has absolutely exposed our robotic
politicians who are bought and sold by
campaign contributors openly Mocking
Hillary Clinton for showing up to his
wedding because he gave her a donation
in many ways.
His message of a broken system corrupted
by money is exactly the same thing that
Bernie Sanders is saying.
Trump has also talked about America's
awful trade deals with China and Mexico
and promise to negotiate better ones.
And actually there's every reason to
believe that he would be good at this
after all,
making deals is what he has built his
empire on.
People actually attack trump for having
his trump brand ties made in Mexico.
But that actually proves his point about
our bad trade deals.
He's making things to sell where cost is
cheap and profit will be maximum.
As an American businessman,
he's doing what's best for his business
by making ties in Mexico.
It's not the fault of the businessman
who uses the system.
That's the fault of the politicians who
set up the bad deals which enable it.
Trump has also brought the issue of
immigration to the front and center of
the debate.
He says he'll build a wall and have
Mexico pay for it.
While I think that Mexico actually may
end up building the wall and paying for
it to keep Americans out,
if he becomes president,
he makes a serious populous point with
the wall.
Trump always says,
we either have a country or we don't.
A wall in and of itself isn't racist.
It may not be wise and it may not
address the real problems,
but when he talks in simple language
like that,
he scores points with many voters.
Having secure borders shouldn't be a
partisan issue,
but because of our politically correct
climate,
it's become one.
You can be for better border security
and still not be a big.
That shouldn't be too hard to
understand.
Finally,
he is also scored points with many
people and talking about the spread of
Islamic extremism.
While trump never takes the time to make
the distinction between Islamic
extremism and the average Muslim person,
he scores points by even talking about
Islamic extremism in the first place
because the left in this country refuses
to do so.
This failure on the left to tackle the
topic of Islamic extremism,
honestly,
by linking doctrine with action,
actually helps feed those like trump who
come in with easy answers with no nuance
or real understanding.
Trump sees an opening for an easy answer
here,
like banning all Muslims from entry to
the country and he runs with it.
Turn on any cable news channel to see
the list of bad things about Donald
Trump.
We've heard them all before,
so I'm actually going to take a
different road here.
Let's talk about what the real threat of
a Donald Trump presidency is.
Donald trump is a businessman making
business decisions,
but he's also a reality TV host.
Winning the world's biggest reality TV
show over the course of his presidential
campaign.
Trump has made it clear that he will say
anything,
literally anything just to be elected.
He uses the media is need for clicks and
views to fuel his rise,
knowing full well.
The more outlandish his statements are
and the more clownish he acts,
the more free tv time he's going to get.
He has mastered the age old adage.
Any publicity is good publicity.
People like trump for his lack of
political correctness,
but it's not what he says that they're
responding to.
It's just that he's saying nothing and
everything at the same time without
sounding like a career politician.
Is He really against gay marriage now,
even though he used to be for it,
is he really against abortion now,
even though he used to be pro choice,
I have no idea what's in his heart,
but I do know what's in his head.
He wants to be the contestant who
doesn't get fired on the season finale.
Many people in this country want to feel
like America is winning again and trump
has wisely use this notion to fuel his
campaign,
but the question is,
what does electing trump actually mean?
If he wins,
does anyone think he'll actually adhere
to the constitution?
Will he care about due process or
respect the three branches of
government?
Will he sue reporters who investigate
the White House where we get into a war
over a mistaken,
retweet his gruff language and loose use
of facts or only the micro problem here
at the macro problem is that nobody
really knows what this guy stands for
other than winning,
and that's the real risk of a trump
presidency.
We have no idea what the country will
look like after we elect someone who
cares more about his own rules than the
law of the land.
You know,
he says,
starbucks will put merry Christmas back
on cups when he's president.
Does he know that the president doesn't
get to decide what a private company
does with their products as a business
man?
Yeah,
he does know,
but as a presidential candidate,
he doesn't care if winning at all costs
for a temporary feel good moment is good
for you,
then by
all means,
you should vote for Donald trump,
but don't be fooled.
You're being sold a bill of goods by
someone who only cares about making the
deal when the product sucks.
Don't expect to get a refund.
My guest this week is the author of
gorilla mindset,
a lawyer,
a twitter,
and a free speech activist.
Mike Cernovich.
Welcome to the show.
Thanks for having me on.
It's a,
it's good to have you here.
We've done this in 140 characters.
I say that to a lot of my guests,
but the whole nature of our relationship
is 140 characters.
And uh,
are you gonna be able to expand on 140?
I have.
I have a podcast too.
I can run my mouth so it talks to each
other.
Alright,
there you go.
So let's start off just so for the
people that don't know you,
tell me a little bit about your history,
where you come from and uh,
and what got you to write the book and
then we'll,
we'll dive into that.
Okay,
cool.
So I'm a grew up small town kid,
flyover state,
which everybody hates now because we're
all redneck,
backwoods,
hateful,
bigoted people.
So I grateful I ever.
It was that Illinois.
Okay,
so I grew up in the middle of Illinois
and nothing but corn fields and soy bean
farms and I realized that I don't really
like this.
I want to do something more with my
life.
Growing up I was also kind of a fat kid,
got bullied a lot,
got picked on.
Then I got into martial arts and started
sort of beating up the people who
bullied me and created that little
conflict cycle.
Got that out of my.
That's the bullied dream,
right?
That's the.
I guess that's the bullied kid dream is
that you get bullied for awhile.
See some martial arts.
You kick some ass.
Well I got.
I got back in everybody but one guy,
but he went to prison for it,
so I was actually home when I was 22 and
I saw this guy went into the bathroom
and I was going to go and just slam his
head and my friend goes,
what is wrong with you man?
You,
your.
This happened when you were like 13
years.
Yeah,
22 now,
you know.
I was like,
yeah,
okay.
Yeah.
Got Got that out of my system.
It's funny because a lot of people do
seem to repeat the things that happened
to them when you were 13,
like if you were bullied people,
they then become the bullies adults.
Right,
and that's probably why I hate bullies
so much now it's just you realize these
people are trying to ruin lives and it's
as bad as bad vibe when you're a kid.
Now I don't really like calling adults
being bullied.
Hey,
you're an adult.
You should know how to or you're being
online bullied.
Okay.
You should learn how to kind of chill
out a little bit,
but I.
I don't like a lot of online bullying
stuff that goes on in terms of,
Oh,
you tweeted something wrong.
Let's ruin this guy's life.
Let's get him fired from.
And in many ways,
let's get the guy fired over.
A tweet is probably worse than throwing
a kindle locker room because that guy
has a family and that's his livelihood.
Or what happened with say,
Justine Sacco,
you know you can't find a job and like,
well maybe that is even a little bit
worse.
Know what happens,
right,
so that's a little bit of a sidebar,
but just in case you want to just lay
that out because it was really.
I mean,
nobody really knew who this woman was.
She put out one tweet,
you can.
Adjusting.
Soco is the best example of the outrage
culture.
She was a nobody.
Hundred and 20 followers,
all of her friends and she tweeted
heading to Africa,
hope I don't get aids.
Oh wait,
I can't.
I'm white,
lol.
Right?
Got a joke.
Yeah,
you're just stupid.
She was a hipster.
She was actually trying to be ironic and
she gets on a plane for Africa back then
he had have wifi on the plane to Africa
and she's in the air and I shouldn't
laugh.
It's actually a tragic story.
They started a Hashtag.
Has Justine landed yet everybody now
hates justine sacco.
She's evil.
Nobody said,
hey,
what'd you mean by this?
You know,
what's going on?
And to be clear,
nobody really knew who this person was.
So this was just the perfect example of
the Internet going crazy.
Yeah,
she was a nobody.
She wasn't a public figure.
She didn't work in tech.
What happened?
Probably one of her coworkers saw it and
wanted to do a little backstabbing.
It was somebody made personal drama,
international news.
Everybody went after her and it touches
on so many themes were.
Well,
I mean that's a woman.
She was getting.
Rape threats are the people,
the social justice warriors,
the activist.
If you're leading a sort of hate mob on
a woman who gets raped,
threats will wait.
Isn't that what you say?
I do,
but I've never done that.
I would never do that.
Okay,
so let's hold off on some of the social
justice stuff first,
but.
And by the way,
I want to go on the record.
I did not jump on that twitter bandwagon
because I remember thinking this is
crazy.
This is just some person who said some
stupid things,
so I can't be outraged by somebody I
never heard of until I saw this little
tweet,
but a little bit back to your history
and then we'll look up on some of the
others.
Yeah,
so then I was deciding on where to go to
law school.
I looked at a map.
I,
I read that the data,
the data says you're gonna live within
50 miles of where I go to law school
statistically speaking,
and I go,
well if I go to law school in Illinois
that means my life will be a little
strip on Illinois.
I said,
I'll move to California.
Kind of too big of a language.
I'm too afraid to go live in la to go to
ucla because I was too big of a pussy to
go live in La.
I'm a small town kid.
I'm driving on the 10 for the first
time,
like Oh shit,
you know,
how do people,
how do people drive traffic?
But I figured that I could go to
pepperdine in Malibu and then I could
kind of visit las.
I wanted to.
So Malibu is a very small town vibe.
Best of both worlds.
Yeah.
And you're right on the beach.
It's pretty,
pretty sweet operation over there at
pepperdine.
I mean,
you know how it is wherever you are,
you don't appreciate what you have first
couple of days.
It's magical.
Majestic.
After that you just look into the law
books anyway.
Right.
Okay.
So you,
so you became a lawyer,
but then really what put you into the
public space was you wrote your book,
the gorilla mindset.
Yeah.
And it's very much a.
I'll let you explain it,
but the,
my main takeaway is sort of that you
control your destiny is sort of the,
the takeaway that I got.
But what made you write it and is that,
do you think that's a fair assessment?
Yeah,
it's you,
you see defined within certain confines,
your own reality.
You know,
you're Dave Rubin on Mike Cernovich.
Your life is your life.
My life is my life,
but we're going to have different
experiences in terms of how you live on
a day to day basis,
but we got the same drama.
We're pissed off at people.
We don't feel like we got recognition.
We wonder if we're gonna lose our jobs.
How am I gonna make money doing this.
What if I,
you know,
ask that girl or guy out on a date or
what if they think I'm dumb.
I'm,
I'm afraid to go on TV because people
think I look stupid.
I sound funny.
What if I say the wrong thing,
we all got the same problems,
you know,
how am I going to pay my bill?
So ultimately you want to control your
thoughts.
You want to control your emotions,
learn how to,
to not lose it essentially.
And the reason I wrote this because I
went through a lot of drama,
had a lot of,
you know,
you grew up,
you grew up poor,
now you're in the big city,
you've got to figure it out.
You have,
um,
you see this in a lot of writing
actually,
where people tend to be ashamed of their
upbringing.
So instead of saying,
Hey,
I grew up a poor kid in a small town,
but hey,
here,
here I am.
Now you want to say,
yeah,
I hate rednecks.
And because you want to get away from
that,
right?
So you kind of overreact.
Well why is that?
Because your mindset,
it's the way you're framing your
background.
So what we tend to do is we think,
well,
I grew up this poor dumb kid.
Why would I ever do with my life?
But you can just say what I mean.
I grew up a poor dumb kid.
I'm here.
I made it somehow I've,
I've learned and I've grown and I start
to take these background experiences and
create a new future out of those.
Yeah,
it's interesting the way we sort of
fetishize being the recipient of
bullying or being the recipient of sort
of anything bad.
So I think for me I was bullied as much
as I bullied other kids.
You know what I mean?
Like I really,
I had some kids that I probably bullet,
I don't like the word either.
It just,
it's so played out,
it doesn't even mean anything,
but I probably treated some kids pretty
shitty and the,
the kids that were higher on the social
thing in high school treated me pretty
shitty and here I am so,
so big wheel,
big deal.
But we have this idea somehow that if
you're always on the recipient end of
it,
but somehow your better.
And that's a really bizarre thing and I
guess that goes to the heart of your
book.
You have to be the one to say,
well,
I'm not going to be bullied anymore.
Right?
Yeah.
Well,
we ultimately define our realities based
on other people and there's a lot of
reasons for that and we should.
And I teach you don't do that.
So for example,
shame.
We've all been ashamed.
Oh my God,
I'm embarrassed.
Well,
why?
Oh,
some complete stranger thinks you're an
idiot,
right?
Well,
why are you letting that other person to
find your own reality?
Which is what you do when you let people
shame you,
attack you,
sort of bullying you.
You're now saying,
well,
I'm going to let other people control
how I feel.
And then he started to think,
well,
why would I let other people control how
you feel?
How does this make any sense of my life?
And then he start to reframe that,
that kind of stuff,
and to a stronger mindset.
Yeah.
So that concept is very much in line
with the online culture.
And I know you're a big part of this
because I see you,
I see you fighting with people online.
You're calling people out,
people are attacking you.
I mean,
you're really in it,
in the,
in the sort of like back and forth piece
of it.
Um,
so I guess the way you deal with that is
that you just don't take any of it too
personally,
right?
You can't take them personally and you
always have to.
You always got to take a negative
rifampin.
It,
reframe it as a positive it cliche,
but you could say,
oh my God,
I have all these people saying mean
things about me.
Or You could just say,
wow,
this is great.
How do these idiots that I've never
heard of hear about me?
Well,
I must be doing something right.
It must be making impact.
So you can let criticism define you.
Madonna said this one's actually,
she goes,
if I go into a room and there are 100
people and 99 people like me and one
person doesn't,
that one person who doesn't like me,
that's what sticks with me.
And we,
we tend to be hardwired as human beings
to let criticism bother us,
which makes sense because if we're
living in a small tribe,
150 people there,
if five guys don't like you,
you know,
they might take you out on the hunting
trip and kill you.
Right?
But we're not in that environment
anymore.
We're in a big global environment.
I've even written about,
you know,
you just have to niche.
If,
if 99 percent of the world hates me one
percent like me,
dude,
I'd be filthy rich.
That would be great.
You know,
I would,
I would love to have 99 percent of the
world hate me.
I mean that's always reminds me of the
thing from Howard Stern's book and in
the movie when they're talking about the
executives are like,
you know,
the people that like you watch you for
four minutes and the people that hate
you watch or listen to you for three
hours or something.
Well my haters dredge up posts that I
wrote maybe when I was in a bad mood or
whatever.
And I'll,
I don't even remember this.
Like how do you guys find this stuff?
Or they'll,
they'll cite confronting you with
things.
I know you.
I'm like,
wow,
you guys are great.
You're pulling up these archives that I
don't even remember.
Right?
So that's a good,
a good transition for everything I think
that's going on in the country right
now.
Because everyone's outraged all the
time.
We're all offended all the time.
We're looking for people to attack all
the time.
Incomes Donald trump into this thing.
Now you're a Donald Trump supporter,
right?
Yeah.
Endorsed Donald Trump,
endorsed Donald Trump.
Uh,
I believe you're the first trump
supporter that I've had on the show.
So congratulations on that.
Uh,
I shared my feelings at the beginning
about trump,
but before I give you more of my
feelings,
so give me why is this working for
trump?
Truth working like them or not this.
Nobody's reading that.
Okay?
So when you have a reaction,
you're going to have a counter reaction.
Here's the world we live in.
You're a liberal.
You're a reasonable guy.
Okay?
That's not most liberals that just,
not sadly,
I'm with you on that.
That's just reality.
We've now taken God who's dead.
We don't have religion.
We now have the religion of political
correctness.
The liberals have now turned into a
religion where you know,
I can say,
well,
you believe these things.
Well,
I think you're wrong.
Maybe if we talk about it,
I'll just get through to you.
Well,
now I don't even look at how you live.
You make a bad tweet,
your evil,
you think something about this,
you're a bad person.
You know?
I always use an example of,
you know,
like a lot of people have facebook drama
by people who knew him and this happened
recently,
so we know this guy,
great guy,
he's actually liberal,
all these liberal friends and he posted,
you know guys,
I just think it's weird that Bruce
Jenner now like as a woman and it's
Caitlin.
I just think it's really weird that you
would want to do that.
And his friends were like,
oh my God,
you're transphobic big.
I can't believe you said this.
They were texting back channel.
I thought this was a good person,
but it's weird,
right?
This is a guy who you've only known to
be a decent guy for all time.
He says something that probably a lot of
people are actually thinking privately.
Like there's something I want to say
weird.
I know Trans People,
Trans people are our great people.
I have obviously no issue with them,
but somebody could say that and that in
and of itself doesn't make them a well,
I'm weird.
You're weird.
Why do you want to be on TV?
Right?
Why do I have a podcast?
Why do I troll the Internet bullied when
I was right?
That's the whole thing.
It's this concept that if you live a
lifestyle that is deviant,
deviant doesn't necessarily always mean
bad.
Weird doesn't mean a moral judgment.
It just means wow,
that's out of the realm of my
experience.
Right?
A lot of people saw what I did early on
before I caught on.
I was like,
no,
trust me,
like I know what I'm doing,
but they're like,
dude,
you're on twitter.
You're just a maniac.
What are people going to think?
And I go,
just try.
But if people said,
Mike,
I think that's weird.
I think it's a waste of time.
Maybe you're mentally ill.
I would say,
ah,
I get it.
You're wrong.
I get it right now.
I don't think you're a bad person for
making that judgment,
so a lot of times we want to now think
everything is a character attack when,
when ultimately you're just saying,
well,
this is fucking weird.
I don't really understand it and what
you do when somebody doesn't understand
something and you say,
well actually I mean is gender binary?
What about brain?
But then you get into other issues too
where you're saying,
well,
I thought gender is a social construct
and there is no male female brain,
but if there's no male brain and no
female brain,
then how can I be a male body with the
female brain?
Right.
And it's hard to extrapolate all that on
twitter.
So instead people are just like,
you hate everybody.
Yeah.
So the interesting thing,
and then we'll get back.
The trouble with the,
with the Trans situation is that,
you know,
Caitlyn Jenner,
now people are turning the left is
turning on her now because she said that
she's supporting Ted Cruz and I watched
it.
I've never watched any of that show,
but I did watch the little five minute
part where she was sort of defending why
she's a Republican and you know,
they're debating and the people,
you know,
she's arguing with these housewives or
whatever these people are that have no
idea what they're talking about,
but I've seen now people on the left
turning on her because she has a
different political view.
So two months ago she was a hero to
them.
But now you think differently
politically,
so now you're evil and that there's a
danger there.
Yeah,
and I'll confess that I did watch the
show for research.
We'll call her research Sherita and a
Caitlin's position was,
hey,
we're 7 trillion in debt.
I like,
yeah,
we should be able to use the same
restrooms,
but come on like if the country falls,
everybody's gone.
You know.
So it isn't even that the views are
wrong,
the views are just,
hey,
I'm focused on bigger issues.
You know,
what happens to a country if our economy
collapses,
well you're going to have a lot bigger
worries then can you use the unisex
bathroom?
And.
But people know they don't want to see
it.
So what happens now is you get fixated
on this marginal issue.
There's this issue that only affects a
real small group of people and then
you're not allowed to focus on any other
issues or else you're evil.
So yeah,
I'm Caitlin would say,
well,
I support Ted Cruz.
Ted Cruz is wrong about this,
but hey,
we got really bigger issues and that
makes you a bad person.
Right?
So for the person that loves identity
politics,
this is like a real disconnect for them,
right?
Because they're like,
wait a minute,
your trans.
So the thing that you're supposed to
care about most of these trends,
and here you have someone saying,
well actually I care more about the
economy or security or whatever it is.
And identity politics as I always say,
widows us down to the point where if you
jump out of that little box,
people start freaking out.
Well,
here's what everybody says now,
well,
as a white,
straight CIS man,
my experienced this,
this,
and will as a gay man,
my experiences as an,
as a.
So we've taken this sort of personal
narrative and now we treat that as like
absolute reality.
There is no issue other than your narrow
slice of experience.
And I think that is not.
I don't think it's a fun way to live.
I don't know why anybody would want to
live that way.
It's a very narcissistic,
narrow view on the world where what you
want to do is you want to think,
well,
there's a lot of us.
We live in a pluralistic society.
We got gays,
Jews,
Muslims,
blacks,
whites,
everybody else.
Why don't we just figure out how to get
along because we're stuck here together.
Right?
And it's almost as if all of those
groups that you decided have people
within them who think different things
than the,
uh,
the bigger group.
I don't know why that's such a
revolutionary thought,
but it seems to be for a lot of people.
So wait,
we started here with trump.
I don't know how we got over there.
So.
Okay,
so you take all of this,
uh,
this social justice stuff and this fear
of saying what you think and all that.
And that basically has led us to trump,
right?
Right.
Because trump says anything.
Here's what people say,
why do you like trump?
Because they'll say what's,
what's on his mind?
And then people go,
well,
we say what's on our mind when we tell
you that if you're a white man,
you hate everybody,
you know,
you're vague it.
It's like,
yeah.
And now you have the counterculture.
Countercultures will trump is just going
to say whatever's on his mind.
That's counter to your narrative.
And people like that.
People respect it.
Okay.
So I'm with you on that portion of that
piece of trump.
I understand.
I'm,
I hate political correctness.
The whole show has been devoted to
fighting it.
So I understand that portion of it with
trump.
But I think you just said something
interesting.
He'll say anything.
And that's where I see the biggest
problem.
This guy,
people keep saying,
well,
I like him because they'll say anything.
But he's also saying nothing.
At the same time.
He's taken every position on everything.
He watched him in the debates.
He stands now for things he used to be
against.
In many ways he's,
he's actually for big government.
He certainly not a conservative all of
those things.
So is that enough for you?
That's the part that I just don't
understand.
I get people are on it on the emotional
level,
but is that in and of itself enough for
you to vote for somebody and be like,
this guy.
Okay,
I'll talk about people first.
I'll talk about me.
So people first,
everybody now knows people lie.
Okay.
Obama said in the debates what?
Eight years ago he was asked if he
supported gay marriage.
What did he say?
Yeah,
he didn't at the time,
but he did.
We all know we did.
Right?
We all know,
we all know that Obama isn't a Muslim or
we all know the obamas almost certainly
agnostic is certainly not a Muslim.
He's almost certainly not a Christian.
We all knew in those debates he
supported gay marriage,
but he couldn't say it.
So now the ruse.
It's all over.
We know they're all liars.
They're all scammers there.
You know Obama's drone struck.
People killed all kinds of innocent
people.
Those wars keep going on.
Not a single Wall Street executive has
been indicted.
We know of Clinton.
Oh,
I'm tough on Wall Street.
We know not a single person.
We all know it's bullshit.
We all know it's a scam.
So then what happens is if it's a scam,
well then you just go with the best
showman and that's where we are now in
life.
We're going to go with the best show.
That's people.
Now,
me personally,
here's what I think trump is ultimately
I,
and this could be my own delusions,
but my views and trump's are very
similar in that I'm a libertarian with
nationalist tendencies,
and what that means is you got to close
the border.
You've got to make sure the right people
get in.
You can't let intolerant people in and
then large amounts of social freedom
within the country,
and that's always been trump's position.
That's what I said.
Well,
trump is a liberal on this.
Of course he is of course,
is if you live in a society where people
can kind of get along and you lead them
the right people,
then you can be socially liberal.
Right?
But do you think that the ends justify
the means?
I guess that that's where I'm struggling
with this situation with him because I
think that ultimately,
and this is what I said at the top of
the show,
if he got in,
this is not someone who would respect
any law that we have.
I don't think he would accept that the
executive branch,
that the president is only one third of
the government.
I think he would do whatever he wants.
The example I gave is that,
you know,
he,
because he says anything,
he said,
well I'm going to,
when I'm president of starbucks is going
to put merry Christmas back on Chris on
their coffee cups.
That's a car.
I know.
It's just that I got you already.
You know,
like he's just saying something crazy.
But I think that that line of thinking
is actually dangerous.
Isn't that what leads us to fascism when
you have a guy who comes in and says,
I'm going to do whatever I want.
I mean,
he's telling us right now.
Right,
right.
Well,
one of my specialties that's actually
common law.
The three branches of government issue
mentioned who has the power to declare
war,
the sole power to declare war congress
has the power.
How many words that we had since World
War Two?
Uh,
probably 15.
How many times?
600.
I'm not sure.
How many times is Congress declared war,
right?
Probably once or.
Yeah,
it hasn't happened.
So we've had Vietnam,
Korea war,
a police action.
Uh,
the Iraq,
the first one,
the second Iraq war,
Afghanistan.
All right.
Libya,
which Obama did.
The executive hasn't respected the
legislative branch for a long time.
And what's interesting is that you can
go back to before Obama was elected and
you can see liberal saying we have an
executive out of control.
No sub,
right?
And then when Obama was elected,
the Conservatives at the Cato Institute
and everybody like Obama's,
you know,
out of control and,
but they all flip flopped on the issue.
So again,
as a constitutional law school,
and I actually am a constitutional law
scholar.
It's all bullshit.
Anyway.
Everybody,
everybody flip flops on who now?
Trump,
what can you really do?
Right?
You can't really do that much.
That's the idea that the president is
that powerful.
He's going to be stopped.
Meaning what?
Meaning he's the really crazy stuff that
people think you're not going to round
up 12 million people.
Okay.
You're not going to create a federal
police force.
Round up 12 million people start kicking
down doors.
It just,
it's,
it's not gonna happen.
Right,
and actually I don't think that's really
what he wants also,
but he's saying that's what I'm saying
here,
this idea,
if you just follow the ideas of what he
saying,
this leads us to a bad place.
This is a no defense of the
establishment and I get it.
I have given Obama Shit on right now.
We're bombing Syria right as we sit here
with no congressional authorization,
so I get it.
They all do this terrible stuff,
but I think the through line of the
trump thinking leads us to a guy for
years later who,
who will be next that that's what I fear
here.
Who will be next?
I don't know.
Right.
That's the thing is I wish I could see
the future,
but what if trump actually does a great
job?
What if trump actually takes on Wall
Street?
What if trump does solve the problem
with the water,
which is a problem.
Our social services our way over stress.
Now we,
we can't.
Anybody who's ever gone to an er in
California talk to any er doctor,
it is.
It is a real mess.
So what trump is doing is he's setting a
cultural town.
He's just saying,
okay,
we got to figure this stuff out,
which,
which is what we need to do.
Okay?
Adults need to sit down at the table and
figure out,
okay,
we have illegal immigrants.
What are we going to do?
Well,
the path that everybody is taken is to
say,
well,
yeah,
well maybe amnesty,
maybe you know,
a path decisions chip,
maybe this and maybe it will clear up
the border and maybe we'll do this.
Maybe we'll do that.
Well,
it's time to actually take an extreme
position because what happens,
right?
The overton,
you know,
negotiation.
How much do you want?
Well,
I want a billion dollars a year.
You're out of your mind,
but now you've anchored and and all this
stuff is cognitive bias persuasion,
the anchoring bias,
right?
He's very open about this by the way,
about how he would negotiate.
He says,
I'm just staking out something crazy.
Right?
So there've been all these studies
that'll show if I say,
well,
how many books do you think we're in the
library of Alexandria?
Twenty million or 1 million.
Well,
depending on if I say 20,
if I say,
do you think there was 20 million or
more?
You'll say,
well,
I think there was 30 million.
Right?
But if I say,
well,
do you think there was more than 1
million or less than a million books in
there?
You're going to be closer to a million.
All because of the anchoring.
Cognitive bias.
So trump is just creating an anchor,
a really strong anchor point,
and then from there you work your way
down and most people don't do that in
your real life.
Most people you think,
okay,
I want this job.
Well I better ask for a salary pretty
close to what I think they'll give me.
Asked for 50 percent more,
right,
because they're not going to say,
well that's,
you've asked her way too much,
would you just not get hired at all?
Now you've anchored or bigger number on
them and now you have a little bit of
leverage and then you work from there.
So interestingly,
what trump is doing in certain way is
really what people on the left do,
which is used feeling over Faq.
So I don't think you're defending him on
the fact based stuff.
Right?
This is all emotional,
right?
You're defending him on the emotional
based stuff.
So that's,
that's fascinating because I see people
on the right all the time.
Say I had Ben Shapiro who sat in that
chair a couple of weeks ago saying,
you know,
all the people on the left care about
feeling more than fact.
And what you're saying basically is that
trump is using that very tactic and yet
he's running.
I'm on the right so by all humans.
So it's,
it's.
He really should be running on the left
and then they would all love him because
he's giving them field.
If it was just the feel good stuff,
that they feel good about it,
he's just giving the people on the right
something that they feel good about.
I'm Ted Cruz and I'm a constitutionalist
who believes in liberty and the founding
fathers.
Right,
okay.
Is there a logical statement there that
you can analyze?
Well,
he believes in liberty and that he
doesn't want people to marry who they
want.
Yeah.
What does Liberty Nice.
Right?
Liberty as you imposed,
there was a great scene in Magnolia.
I think that musical movie,
and they go liberty fraternity.
Well,
who could oppose liberty?
Right?
We all do,
but we have a different conception of
liberty.
If I'm a fundamentalist Christian,
well I want religious liberty and I
think religious liberty means I
shouldn't have to bake a cake for gay
people were okay.
If you're gay,
you think,
well,
I'm an adult.
I should be able to enter into contracts
about my relationship with other
consenting adults.
So if I just say,
well,
I support liberty.
So then what'd you do as you say?
Well,
Ted Cruz doesn't really support my
conception of liberty,
but it's all bullshit.
I support the constitution.
Fuck this.
What does that even mean?
Right?
There's a lot in the constitution.
Do you believe abortion is in the
constitution or not?
Right?
What does it protect?
So the idea that politicians run on
these logical points and that people
make their conclusions based on logic is
nonsense.
So yeah,
it is funny when people facts over
feelings.
Well,
I mean look at that,
you know,
not to get too far ahead.
Look at that Michelle fields incident.
We just had,
you know,
oh I was grabbed and almost thrown to
the ground and this man.
And then you watched the video.
You know,
it's still unclear to me.
So for people that don't know what
you're talking about,
basically trump's campaign manager
apparently grabbed Michelle fields who
was a breitbart reporter.
She showed a little bit of a bruise on
her arm in a picture.
I've watched the video a thousand times.
It's still,
I just,
I don't know.
I've been in those scrums a little bit,
but I've been to those things.
Yeah,
you get people get pushed and pulled and
whatever.
So I don't really know what happened.
So I'll leave it there,
but I.
But your basic take on it is that she's
a bullshit artist.
Yeah.
It's all.
It's all been overplayed.
She sat on TV.
Well,
other than my dad dying.
This is the worst thing that's ever
happened to me in my life.
Everybody,
every.
C'Mon.
Everybody uses feelings to manipulate
people.
If,
if you're about to be fired from a job,
you can make two cases.
Well,
you know,
here's an excel sheet.
Here's how many of you as I bring you
can bring that into.
And we go way back and you promised me
this last.
All emotions,
right?
We make most of our decisions based on
emotions.
We respect leaders based on we're
monkeys were fucking monkeys,
right?
We want to think we're better than that.
And Donald Trump right now is the big
Alpha Monkey.
So okay,
so let's talk about the Alpha part
because I definitely think that's part
of it.
And he just is up.
They're exerting his alpha male is.
And the rest of these guys simply aren't
Alpha males.
So you can take a Marco Rubio who even
though I disagree with on most things,
I think he's probably a decent human
being and he's in the right line of
work.
He's actually looked kind of human now
that he's realized he's over.
He's looking kind of human as opposed to
the robot that we've been seeing up
there.
But you look at him,
that's certainly not an Alpha male.
You look at a Ted Cruz,
just creepy car salesman,
you know,
the rest of them.
Ben Carson basically asleep.
So you know like.
So is that really part of it that we
really are just looking for somebody to
just get that feeling from us and it's
like now I'll follow you
and survive.
It is,
it's definitely a vibe.
It's all unconscious.
Ninety percent of communication you.
I mean,
you know this,
right?
Anybody is ever dated,
you know,
if you're across from a woman,
well man,
you know,
whatever the case is,
you know the person's like this looking
at their phone,
that's a vibe.
Right?
Every week.
And we go based on vibes.
But we as human beings want to believe
that we're logical and that we make
conclusions based on what we.
We look at the evidence and we have all
this information and stuff.
We don't know.
We don't have all the information that
the media lies about things.
The government lies about things.
We have no idea.
The Federal Reserve has never been
audited.
We have no idea about anything.
And that's scary.
It's scary to think that I'm just a
regular schmuck who knows nothing.
It has no control.
But that's where the growth mindset
comes in.
I'm sort of like,
so people are always like,
oh yeah,
you're probably there should probably
that.
I'm like,
man,
if you know,
we have met in real life,
I'm pretty mellow in real life because I
realized like I found a fucking control
over shit man.
Like I have control much more measured
here.
You on twitter.
I didn't know what I was walking into.
I have a little bit of control over how
I feel and what I think that's about it.
The rest of the world is sort of out of
my control.
So we talked about this pre show,
you know your life is your life.
People think Obama's going to save them
or ruined them.
People think that sanders is going to
save them or unum.
People think that Hillary is going to
ruin the life.
The same with trump.
Why?
Why is trump going to ruin your life or
make your life and that isn't even
really a healthy way to go about it.
So people feel ms dot saver though.
But back to the original point is that
yeah,
he's got that vibe.
He's got that swagger.
He's got watch them work and audience,
right?
I always tell people turn off and stand
up half the day.
Oh,
I said this and Obama is a Muslim.
And trump's,
oh,
I didn't say he said it.
Oh well I'll repeat what he said.
Well don't you dare say that I said
Obama's a Muslim.
I just.
Or with the Ted Cruz is a pussy.
Well,
I didn't say it but.
Oh,
you didn't hear what he said.
Oh well that guy said,
ted Cruz is a pussy.
But come on,
I would never say that I'm running for
president.
I mean that's good shit man.
So that's the.
That's the interesting thing here
because I want people to say whatever
they want and we all know it's bullshit
and they go to Congress and they said,
Oh,
the gentlemen from blog and it's like we
know you all hate each other and you're
all making side deals and all that.
So unmasking that is all good and that's
the part of the trump thing.
The train that I can get on.
So maybe there will be some good.
The other part I can't get there.
The part about the policy stuff and what
he really believes,
and I get what you're saying.
You're basically saying that stuff
doesn't matter because there's.
Because Shit's going to go down either
way.
I just can't get there on that,
but I do.
I accept your premise as to why other
people can get their.
Trump has politically.
If I had to guess politically centrust,
I would put him to the right of Obama,
but to the left of everybody else
running,
which is why it all cracks me up,
that everybody on the left is scared
shitless to trump.
Trump is actually,
he's a Rockefeller Liberal,
New York liberal,
but he does want to do something about
immigration.
He's.
He's raised a discussion that,
and I've traveled in the Middle East,
I've met Muslims.
There's more to it than America knows.
We don't know the full story on Muslims,
but we do know that isis is sending
people in as,
as refugees.
I know that I went to Budapest,
Hungary and I saw the refugees and they
look like you and me and people like
this and way younger there's 70 percent
men and if you take in 70 percent men,
you don't have enough women,
right?
Because they're mostly heterosexual.
You now have gender disbalance.
How are they going to get late?
What's going to happen?
Are they going to get violent?
These are things that reasonable people
should be able to ask,
but if you even asked that question,
you're done.
So you might as well just say,
fuck it.
Fuck it.
Don't let,
don't let any of them in there because
people are going to say,
you're done anyway.
Right?
So if I just said,
well,
you know,
I was in,
I went to Hungary.
I went to the train stations,
I investigated it for myself,
I did reporting on it.
They're all men,
they're all able bodied.
They're all prime fighting age.
Why are they leaving the women back
home?
What is really going on?
Well,
if you say that your persona non grata
anyway.
Right.
So that's why you look.
Even if you look at the pictures coming
out where the migrants are crossing into
Greece and they're crossing into Germany
and wherever else they're going.
It's all men.
It's all men in their twenties and
thirties,
right?
One hundred percent,
but a huge percentage of it,
and this is where I as a liberal had
been painted into a corner here for the
eight months that I've been doing this
show.
I've tried to talk about the difference
between ideas and people and doctrine
versus the average person that may or
may not be religious and probably isn't
a impressing anyone and doesn't want to
blow anything up.
But I've been left basically with my 10
guys on the left and the whole
conversation has been handed to trump.
So he's just taking the meat,
right?
He's just taking the red meat on this.
Well,
because here's what I learned to and
that's why I'm kind of a little bit
while on twitter as I realized that if
you.
If people ask me,
Mike,
what do you really believe?
Author world,
I would say,
well,
I think that generally speaking,
women enjoy being more feminine and more
supportive role of a man who's more
dominant,
but if you want to be a woman and you
want to be a lawyer or a CEO,
I don't think anybody should stop you
and I think you should be careful not to
tell women what they have to do.
Those pretty boring shit.
Basic Shit.
But if you put that online,
will you contribute to a culture of
internalized misogyny?
That Turkey?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So you can't even say that,
so you might as well say,
fuck it,
I'm the best.
Sex is rough,
sex and women are crazy and they have
wild sexual fantasies and everything
because they're gonna come after you and
so you're doing the trump tactic
yourself and you're admitting it because
basically you're saying,
I'm pretty moderate guy.
If that women can do whatever they want
to do,
in my view,
maybe they're better off at home,
but they can do whatever they want to
do,
but when you're online,
you're staking out this stuff because
you just want to keep rattling the cage
and they're gonna come after you.
Anyway,
that's the thing is feelings versus
facts.
People don't sit down and just have a
rational conversation.
Well,
what do you really think about this?
You know,
people have written about me before
rentable.
My tweets.
Nobody's ever said,
hey,
I read this tweet where he told the guy
to go kill himself.
What did you really mean?
Well,
the guy told him to kill himself,
had actually tried to kill his ex
girlfriend had was at a rehab and burned
with cigarettes,
were real bad guy.
Right?
And he was a troll who wasn't really
going to kill himself.
He was doing the whole,
I'm having a meltdown,
therefore I'm mentally ill because
that's what you do when you do bad
things now,
right?
You gotTa Rehab your claim mental
illness,
but nobody says,
Hey,
what's the context man?
What's the backstory?
So you realize,
well you might as well be a maniac.
You put on a good show.
The people love it.
So when trump.
I didn't know about trump.
That's the funny thing and that's
probably why I saw early on why he was
going to do so well as I watched one
season of the apprentice when I was in
law school 10 years ago,
right?
So I didn't really know anything about
trump and I looked at what he didn't
like him.
He's just doing what I do.
But on a scale that is way bigger than I
do and what you're doing is you realize
that,
okay,
what do people love?
Men,
women,
drama.
People love drama.
People love conflict.
Conflict is attention.
Negative attention.
Pause.
Cause cause you can take a hater and
turn that into a lover,
but you can't turn.
People don't know about you on A.
Yeah.
So you want to get maximum attention?
You know,
I don't watch any reality shows.
I've maybe watched them five minutes of
survivor ever.
I never watched American idol or any of
that stuff.
The only reality show that I've watched
is the celebrity apprentice.
So this was,
you know,
five years ago before he was running for
president.
So that,
I guess says it right there,
there is something about him.
You're not going to convince me to vote
for him by the end of this,
but that I can understand the logic of
it.
Um,
and I thought also that,
you know,
having someone on that's a trump
supporter would be interesting because
everyone's just screaming at each other.
Right.
So we should match the,
the media would love us to be sitting
here screaming at each other.
That would,
that would help the narrative,
right?
Yeah.
It would help the narrative.
You know,
I,
I would get a lot of interview requests
I used to.
They stopped calling me,
they don't email anymore because they
talked to me like,
well,
wait a minute,
you know,
they want me to play pro wrestling
characters.
This is what the media wants and and
that's why I do a little bit online
because I realized like,
okay,
I grew up watching ads,
pro wrestling.
I'm just to heal.
I'm the bad guy.
Right.
Might as well be ric flair,
the million dollar man,
you know,
I might as well just because they're
going to make me one anywhere.
As Mike Tyson said,
I could speak eloquently,
but you're going to call me a fucking
rapist anyway,
so might as well.
Right.
Just be crazy for a second.
Jake,
the snake Roberts was my favorite
restaurant.
He was a good guy,
but it didn't.
Went Back.
Didn't have many friends on his side.
So I feel like maybe that was the right
guy for me.
Yeah,
exactly.
But think about it,
right?
Think about trump.
You.
How hard is immediate game,
right?
How hard is.
Well,
I guess if you're trump,
it's not that hard.
He's.
Well,
that's,
that's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
So you have all these people in the
media,
you know,
you have a personal brand.
I have a personal brand,
but you'll see some guy,
you know the job with the Washington
Post and say trump doesn't know what
he's doing.
He's an idiot.
I'll go on the guy's twitter account and
I'm like,
dude,
you're right at the Washington Post,
and he was like 1500 followers.
Like I have 31 and it's all organic
following,
you know,
I sell more books than these guys and
everything because I'm real.
I know who does what because you can
look at Amazon sales ranks and I'm like,
you don't get it.
The media game is hard.
Trump is winning it.
So maybe instead of saying list guys
evil,
why don't you just take a step back,
breathe and say,
well what is he doing?
And then say,
well why is he doing it?
So That's interesting because I've
noticed in the last few days since the
rally in Chicago that got canceled that
the media definitely,
I hate using the phrase of the media is
it's this monolith,
but the mainstream media and even a lot
of the online stuff,
they've really doubled down now on trump
is evil and all that stuff.
Now again,
I started this show by giving a litany
of reasons why I'm not voting for this
guy.
Um,
but I think that every time buzzfeed
puts out an article saying why he's evil
or every time political does it or,
or,
and especially anything that's on the
left,
right?
So New York magazine or then I think
they're just strengthening him and they
would,
I don't understand is,
do you guys not understand psych 101?
Did none of you go to college because
all you're doing is making him stronger
case to everybody?
Most of them don't understand it,
but some of them do,
but ultimately we're all in a big media
matrix.
Okay,
I'll uncover media hoax and then the
next day I'll be like,
oh yeah,
I wrote this article and the whatever
that I just said yesterday is a piece of
shit,
you know,
now I'm saying,
well that's an interesting story on
this.
So we're all kind of caught in the
Matrix and in that regard,
the savvy people know that they are
ultimately building his brand,
but they're getting clicks,
but they're,
they're getting views.
We just all deserved the bullshit that
at the end of the day,
right,
because everything,
I know for a fact that if we did this
show a little bit differently,
so you know,
in the youtube game for example,
if we titled things a little
differently,
we could double our clicks like that and
I've had many meetings with my guys and
I'm just like,
I'm not going to do it.
I just don't want to build something in
that way,
but plenty of other people are so we all
deserve the crap that we're getting
because we're building the crap.
Yeah.
I tried to have a debate with the guy
once said we had a real civil talk just
like we're talking now and that the
youtube thing went on and he just was a
and I thought,
are we going to scream at each other?
But that's what people want.
You know,
that is.
That is what most everybody screams at
everybody.
Everybody online and she's saying,
well,
you're an Mri,
evil Mrs.
Men's rights activists evil or you evil
as we are evil feminist or an evil that,
that yeah,
that's what people want.
But then it becomes,
you know,
you as an artist,
you have to find your own integrity.
And my integrity.
I think trump's integrity to us.
I ultimately have a very good message.
I wrap it up and drama,
conflict and all that other stuff,
but smart people see through it.
They can kind of say,
okay,
I,
you know,
I kind of see what's going on.
I get,
I see.
To the theatrical,
trump is somebody who cares a lot about
America and he does what nobody else
running does.
Okay.
We are Americans.
We have the right to have an identity as
a nation.
We have the right to have a culture.
We have the right to say you as an
American,
I care more about you than I care about
people in China,
Bangladesh,
Romania,
Nigeria,
nobody else is saying that.
And that's where nationalism comes in.
And that's another reason that he's
doing well is it's this idea that,
yeah,
I'm an American.
You don't hear that much.
Now a lot of people,
even the sort of chattering class,
the so called intellectuals would say,
well,
nationalism is bad and you're part of a
global society.
You think you're part of a global
society,
but go travel somewhere and you'll find
right away that they don't think you're
part of a global society.
So is that why his slogan even make
America great again?
First off,
everyone wants things to be great,
so that's good,
but also throwing the word again in
their implies that we lost something
great.
We're going to get that thing back.
Versus Bernie's,
which is a future to believe in.
So Bernie's not talking about getting a
feeling back.
He's saying,
well,
something out there is pretty good at
trump's gone.
We lost some shit.
So it really,
it's just about which part of the brain
these guys are
todd onto?
Trump packs more information in a slogan
or a tweet than anybody else does.
He jams in Atlanta is worse.
So yeah,
make America great again.
If you're an advertising or marketing
that's aspirational,
you know that if you're in marketing,
you want an app to be an aspirational
good.
Trump is an aspirational.
This is all.
This is what pisses me off fucking
marketing.
How can all these people who claim they
know marketing not just sit and say,
okay,
trump is running an ad campaign.
Trump is an aspirational good.
Trump is saying make America great
again.
That's an aspirational slogan and tying
on nationalistic feelings like America
and make is a very sort of can do word.
Americans have a can do attitude.
I mean the guy who wrote a book about
it,
right?
He's doing what's in his book,
So this stuff used to sort of,
you know,
that's where I have to use the girl
mindset was like maddening.
I'm like,
don't you,
you aren't intelligent people.
You can't just analyze this.
But again,
that's because that's my own weakness
and thinking that people are logical.
If you're logical,
you would just sit down and say,
okay,
here's what trump does.
You read his tweets.
Many people have said that I'm the
greatest man in the world.
What?
What has he done there?
Well,
social proof.
Many people,
because we are a monkey's wealth,
many people think it must be true.
He's not bragging because he's not
saying that that's what many people are
saying,
so a lot of times you could just sit
down and look at trump's tweets,
read them,
and really see that this guy uses
language wall,
so they go,
is an idiot.
He's a buffoon.
And I said,
no,
you're the fucking buffoon because I can
explain it just very logically.
Every he uses social proof.
He uses cognitive biases.
You know,
in college you learn the logical
fallacies to make good arguments.
Well,
what if you're a soft fist and you take
the logical fallacies to trick people to
be a Sophos,
right?
Maybe you're not dumb.
Maybe you're the smart guy because the
reason that you learn to analyze logical
fallacies is because we are lazy
thinkers and fallacies.
Work is just a good way of manipulating.
Yeah.
So maybe you know,
people are like,
Oh,
if you use a logical fallacy,
you're stupid maybe.
But if you're using a logical fallacy,
you get people to draw.
Fall San Francisco.
Marco Rubio's send a foam party.
Well,
I haven't said.
I haven't said anything,
but Marco Rubio said that he was in a
foam party.
Well,
I'm now using the fallacy of getting you
to draw false inference.
That must've been some gay thing.
And is he really in the closet?
Well,
I didn't say that right.
You said it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
I get it.
I fully get what you're saying.
It's such a dangerous slippery slope and
some people are going to play the game.
So I guess that's what it is.
People are angry at him because he's
playing the game at a higher level.
So I tweeted a day or two ago and it's
taking off,
right?
The second thing about it was three
things and it was one,
uh,
I don't support trump.
I do believe in free speech.
If you use your free speech to take away
someone else's,
then one day they will come for you.
And I think that really sums up what's
going on here because if you look at
what happened at the rally the other
night,
it wasn't the government that came in.
So it wasn't a first amendment issue.
The government didn't say,
you're not allowed to say this,
but if we start getting to a place,
and I'm not saying this is exactly what
happened that night because it's a
little unclear who started what and
whatever,
but if we get to a place where everyone
is just using their free speech to shout
down everybody else,
well then we don't have free speech and
it has nothing to do with the
government.
So there's.
There's a huge free speech play here
too,
right?
Yeah.
Well they call it the heckler's veto.
You're going to let one guy scream
everybody else down.
So then whoever has the biggest heckler
is the person who controls the debate
and then yeah,
the broader point you make is perfect
because not to plug my documentary that
we're doing and that we want to talk to
you,
but I'll go away.
That's pissed off a lot of my guys
because it's called silenced our war on
free speech and they go,
no,
it's not.
Our war is a war and we want to think,
well,
there's a war on all of us.
Free thinkers and everything,
but it isn't the government censoring
us.
We're fucking doing it to each other.
I'm afraid if I say the wrong thing to
you,
you're going to think I'm a shitty
person.
You're afraid that if you post the wrong
thing on twitter,
you're going to get fired from your job
or people are gonna come after you.
They're going to call your advertised as
one long thing.
So we're all kind of censoring each
other were really,
why don't we just say,
well,
you know,
you said that.
What do you really mean it?
Oh,
you're a trump supporter.
Will why your trump supporter?
Well,
I'm a maybe.
Maybe if somebody would say,
well,
I'm a trump supporter because I believe
America has the right to exist as a
nation.
Okay,
well,
I don't know.
What do you mean?
Did it.
Did it right?
You just talk.
That's what people should do.
You listen to one another and right now
we don't.
We're all declaring war on each other.
Right?
So That's interesting.
But it goes to the people that are
taking the higher road here or almost
destined to lose then.
Right?
Because if you're taking the higher road
here and you're saying,
I'm going to respect your free speech,
I don't like what you say,
but I'm going to defend your right to
say it.
If you take that road.
Well basically from everything you've
said here,
there's going to be a huge swell of
people that won't do that and thus will
always win with the heckler's veto.
Right?
That that's where I see this all going.
That's why I've been talking to you.
They
were winning,
but now there's a massive counterculture
where people are saying,
you know,
me and Lauren,
the director of the silence,
we say,
we're going to make free speech.
Cool.
Again,
you know,
we don't have an agenda.
We just want people to know that,
you know,
it's cool to share your point of view.
It's cool to talk and more people are
getting that.
If you look at whose profiles are being
raised on twitter,
which is kind of,
twitter is where the future's headed.
That's why I love twitter and we could
do a whole hour and just why I love
twitter.
Twitter is the future.
The future is.
Even though the business is crumbling,
you mean the ideas behind because the
people who are kind of out of,
I don't like the word thought leaders,
but hip smart tech savvy people.
Here's what they're thinking.
They're,
they like people like you.
They like people like Laura southern.
They're like people like Milo,
uh,
they like people like Gavin [inaudible]
guys,
my profile is going.
So the people who are sort of pro free
speech,
their profiles are growing and then
there's a pushback against the
regressive left.
So what had happened is we had given
everybody the heckler's veto to call you
a homophobe or a racist and
misogynistic,
transphobic.
We say one wrong thing and now you're
realizing,
well,
that's shutting everybody speech down.
Now before we have the regressive left,
the sjws we had the moral majority.
We had tipper Gore trying to say,
you can't listen to it because you and I
were,
you know,
I don't want to say we're old,
handsome men are fucking old man.
Like ice tea,
body cow,
cop killer.
Oh my God.
You know,
he's inciting violence.
Uh,
I used to do in bed.
I never asked anyone.
Yeah,
Oh my God,
this kid committed suicide after
listening to Judas priest.
This is satanic music without a bandit.
That's the right.
And then you fall off the right,
the left did,
and then the left came in and now
they're fucking doing it.
And now instead of saying,
well,
video games make you find this a little
bit against Mickey hate women.
And then we have a new counterculture
that's going to push that back.
And then guess what?
Specificity Rock,
you know,
guys like you and me,
our whole fucking life,
we're going to be like,
we'll be in 10 years,
will be finding the right again,
and then in another 10 years we'll find
the left again.
Yeah.
So that center and that bill,
you know,
it's interesting that the people that
you just mentioned there,
like Laura and Lauren and I'm Milo
there,
their role to the right.
And again,
this is,
I always feel like God,
I'm,
I'm the last man standing over here.
Uh,
but yes it is.
It is growing.
So how do we then coalesce around that
knowing that we're,
we're not going to support.
I don't.
I'm not sure who I'm going to vote for
at this point,
uh,
but that we can sit here and do this.
How do we coalesce around that idea that
we need conversation more than we need
everyone judging everybody into
oblivion?
Well,
I have,
I have a little bit of an idealist and I
truly believe if we're talking to each
other,
we're not killing each other.
That's the start,
right?
What a lot of people don't realize if
they haven't studied a lot of history,
we,
you know,
we think we can have a Cambodian
holocaust.
We think that we can't have an Armenian
genocide.
We think we can't have Milo.
Milo is greatly forward or what they had
in the Soviet Union.
Why can't we?
Why are we so special?
Well,
that all started with censorship
culture.
You can't say certain things that
started with us versus them.
For the Cambodian,
the Cambodian genocide,
you had the farmers with real people in
the city.
People were the bad people.
That was identity politics even within a
single race of people.
And then what happens?
You don't talk.
You go to the underground and then the
fucking lunatics talked only other Luna
lunatics because there's still going to
talk and then you have all the lunatics
on the,
on the ground talking to each other.
That's how you get people blowing shit
up.
That's how you get people killing each
other.
Right?
So in an instance where I saw two videos
this week were one,
a trump supporter was at a rally
screaming,
go back to Auschwitz and then another
one,
he was screaming at a,
at a black person,
a go back to Africa.
I think what you're saying is that
there's actually something good there
because it's being unearthed as opposed
to these people just festering.
They're screaming at you,
nobody's hitting each other.
Nobody is.
People are hitting each other so well.
The protest is there's,
there's no more than a music festival
though the line.
I always use this people,
you need to get out more,
go to a rock music festival other than
May pry burning man.
Nobody fights,
but other may you know.
But if you go to a rock concert or rap
concert,
we have people.
You're gonna have people kind of
fighting each other and that's again
media manipulation,
logic verse is cognitive bias.
Okay?
Logically speaking,
if you have multiple rallies with 25,000
people there and you have 10 of them and
there's one fight that,
what is that one in $100,000,
that would be the safest city in the
world.
Right?
But you focus on that one fight and that
becomes the narrative where there's
violence.
Well it was,
it was one 78 year old guy punched a guy
and you know,
the faces sucker punched.
Okay,
well there had been all these rallies
and there's a couple instances.
Logically speaking,
statistically speaking,
that isn't really a big deal.
Well,
first of all,
just to push back on that a little bit,
I mean trump is also offering to pay
that guy his legal fees,
which seems pretty crazy to me.
A guy punched a 70 year old and punched
a black guy walking out regardless of
the,
regardless of his race.
Um,
but punch the guy and trump saying,
I'll pay for your legal fees is a bit.
Can you give me that one?
He offered,
it was a different time that you've,
you've conflated different stories.
So that was a different riot were.
So I guess there's a couple of rides.
There are people there are people
swinging punches.
I mean,
did you see,
um,
did you see what happened when,
yeah,
I don't want to give a guy free
publicity,
but there was a conservative breitbart
speaker who gave a talk at cal state Los
Angeles.
I have videos of a breitbart intern
being thrown to the ground by a black
lives matter protester.
I have the video.
Lauren Feldman,
the director for silence.
We have it.
That didn't make news right?
That suddenly violence goes both ways.
I know everybody likes what the media
likes,
but I have no doubt the violence goes
both ways.
That's the thing.
Everybody's doing it.
So that's the interesting thing too,
about logic versus not logical.
Why don't we objectively count how much
drama is going on at,
at Sandra's event,
right?
Well,
he had a Bernie Sanders supporter jump
over a guard rail to try to go to attack
trump.
Right?
I read the guy's tweets.
The guy is a total nut job.
Yeah,
he's.
He goes on CNN and they treat him like
he is stood up to a bully.
Right.
Well,
why is he standing up to bullies trump?
Why don't you say,
well,
hey,
you don't like trump.
Trump's talking now you're trying to
jump over a guard rail to attack a guy,
and he'd posted on twitter before high
wanting to kill trump and why is that?
Yeah.
It's sort of a nice way to wrap this
thing up.
Although clearly we could have gone a
lot longer than this,
but it shows what a moral mess
everybody's in because I.
I do agree with that.
Look,
I'm not thrilled with the things trump
saying.
Again,
I'm not supporting the guy,
but when that guy rushed the stage,
if you look at the history of this guy's
tweets,
he's a bit of a nut bag.
He said some crazy things and then CNN
treated him like a hero.
Now,
meanwhile,
if a trump supporter had bum rushed,
Bernie Sanders,
everyone not only would say this guy
should be in jail,
but they wouldn't have given him an
interview on CNN,
but they'd also be blaming trump.
So yeah,
there,
there is an unevenness here that we've
got to wrap up,
but I think we did a little evening of
the playing field here.
What do you think?
It's.
We're not logical,
right?
We're,
we're creatures.
We want stories.
You want simple stories of the world.
Trump understands it.
He's playing the game better than
everyone else.
That's why they don't like them,
but yeah,
as long as we're talking,
you're a human.
I'm a human.
You know,
I don't want to kill gay people,
you know,
because I know a gay guy,
right?
I don't want to kill straight white guys
even though I had the worst.
Ultimately,
that's what happens with people.
As you,
as you talk,
talk to each other,
you think,
wow,
I mean you're,
you're saying gay people or this or this
or that,
but I know a guy and he's not like that.
Well,
that's not really large.
I know a guy.
Therefore,
all gay people or this or that is a
logical,
but that's the way we think,
so yeah,
as long as you're talking,
you're reaching out to people who
disagree with you.
Your own illogical brain helps you
become a better person.
That's how you end an interview.
All right,
so I want to thank Mike Cernovich and
you can check out his book,
Gorilla Mindset,
how to control your thoughts and
emotions to live life on your terms.
Oh,
and direct.
All hate directly to him.
It's at Cernovich on the twitter.
Thanks again,
and we'll do it again next week.